wir wollen jetzt auch noch die
geschichte zehn von elf rettern die als
allererstes am unglücksort waren denn
sie wollten dort ein feuer löschen das
vor der mega explosion ausgebrochen war
sie wollten also ihren job machen helfen
und fuhren unwissentlich in den sicheren
tod mindestens elf feuerwehrkräfte gaben
bei der extrusion ihr leben ein
handy-video zeigt die letzten
augenblicke dieser einheit die retter
stehen vor der lagerhalle 12 im hafen
dunkler rauch quillt aus den kaputten
fenstern
man hört sie reden im hintergrund jemand
ruft befehle und aus der halle drohen
mehrere kleine explosionen während die
retter versuchen das tor aufzubrechen
zum brandherd vorzudringen und es zu
löschen
es sind die letzten sekunden im leben
dieser feuerwehrleute zehn der elf
retter hat man bisher nicht finden oder
identifizieren können nur die leiche von
feuerwehrfrau sahara fahrers wurde
identifiziert anhand ihres
verlobungsringes wenn wir jetzt hier
gerade sehen schon kurz nach der
explosion trauerte der gouverneur
öffentlich um die retter und brach in
tränen aus